stephanie's with us in Kentucky hi
Stephanie welcome to the Dave Ramsey
show thanks for taking my call
sure what's up um so about 10 years ago
I graduated from veterinary school I
went to school out of the country
actually so it was a pretty tough night
bill
but because of interest rate and what I
was making at the time I was just on
income-based repayments so they were
pretty minimal not even going towards
the actual principal currently that loan
had grown over $400,000 and to get into
baby step two would I consider that as
part of the loan that I need or the debt
that I need to pay off with a
possibility of having a forgiveness in
the next 20 years would it be better to
just pay off the current that we have
minus that and then work on saving
towards the forgiveness tax bill in the
future there is no forgiveness tax bill
well what do you say you're gonna you're
gonna sit here and bet your life on
Elizabeth Warren getting elected no no
there's there is there is no there is no
what did this bill start out at if it's
up to 400 now I was less than 200,000 I
got out so not that I'm not paying on it
hasn't worked well for you
no but I if I don't make enough to make
the minimum payments to go towards
principal my workers are you working as
overhead yeah yes I'm and my husband has
has a job as well we just yeah we just
don't make it would be over $3,000 a
month in order to do that and that plus
yeah that's more than we make now and we
have a family in house and other debts
so you're a veterinarian and you make
how much this year because I was on
maternity leave it was about 65 supposed
to be about 85 so your normal years
85 yes and how long have you been in
practice uh nine years are you in a
rural community I know you're not making
much no I'm looking into possibly
finding a better paying job but practice
is weak because most dbms are making 105
to 200 not ones that I know but yes I'm
working doing financial coaching for 30
years and I work with them all time they
actually do better than a lot of Doc's
if they manage to practice well and
manage their options well and so forth
so I think what you've got is a hope
problem and a an income problem and you
need to address it or you again I'm
gonna ask are you in a small town or a
metro area that's true okay yeah you
need to you need to do some work on
studying what you should be making in
how you can get there as a comp study
because I'm we work with them Alton we
work with you guys all the time I mean a
bunch of deviants come through on tray
leadership events and I sit and talk to
them I know how their practices work and
and what they're making and so you're
not making anything we I would work in
the next three to five years to double
your income and if I were in your shoes
and then I would work towards and you
don't believe that can happen right now
I hear that I know that but I'm asking
I'm answering the question what what I
do if I were in your shoes because I
know that can happen I see that happen
and then I would go from there and begin
to really cut your lifestyle down you've
got to believe that you can do this but
you know if your husband's career your
career you guys have got to address this
because it's not getting anything but
worse it's going from bad to worse all
the time and waiting on the government
to come up with a plan to forgive
student loans is not really a good
strategy because there's a whole bunch
of people who paid off their student
loans
who probably aren't going to vote that
way
for you to get a free ride so you you're
gonna have a problem with that it's the
problem with the concept so hey thank
you for the call I'm so sorry you're
facing this I know it's overwhelming but
I really do believe that you know really
focusing on your career instead of on
hopelessness and and let's just maximize
hustle and grind let's figure out what
can we do to make more money what can we
do to make more money we open our home
do we did we grow do we work more hours
that we work to different DVM positions
what do we do to get the into milk the
value out of this degree because it is a
valuable degree in terms of economics
and then use that along with your
husband's income him working all the
time and two of you clean this mess up
because otherwise it's gonna get worse
and worse and worse and worse and worse
it's not gonna go away and the
government is not gonna wave a wand for
you I just don't see it happening
okay the juxtaposition of that is you
are 18 years old and you want to go and
get a degree right now you need to
listen to these folks that call in that
have this life at 30 years old and you
need to learn from them what the
mistakes were okay she took out a
high-interest loan she studied in a
overseas setting for the experience
points that added nothing to the value
of her degree we know that because she's
not making more money as a result of
having studied overseas she's making
less than the typical DVM and so
spending extra money to quote have
experiences while you're in school that
you don't have is not a good plan it's
dumb picking a degree you can make good
money with as a result of that field of
study and paying cash for it is smart
and if you want to learn more about that
and you're 18 years old or you have an
18 or 17 year old pick up Anthony
O'Neill's book debt-free degree because
you can go to school debt-free
and you should go to school debt-free
you pick a school that is that fits your
budget and if you're broke it means you
picked the cheapest possible school well
I'd rather go well I know you'd rather
drive a Bentley than a used Chevette but
you have a use Chevette budget you know
if you got a champagne taste I don't
care you got a beer pocketbook baby and
so you need to go to an in-state school
with the in-state tuition if you're
broke
get all the scholarships you can get
your hands on take six jobs and work
your butt off while you're in school and
you can get through school debt-free
and it can be done and then you don't
get caught in these situations and this
idea that it's being pitched out there
on the political trail right now and a
portion of a generation is believing it
which is really sad right there to where
your financial plan is waiting on the
lefty to get elected it's gonna get you
in trouble because it's intellectually
dishonest to talk about forgiving
student loan debt while we're still
making trillions of dollars of student
loans the first thing you do is you cut
the faucet off Washington regardless of
which side of the aisle you're on in
this discussion that's just
intellectually dishonest to keep making
the loans while you talk about forgiving
existing loans that's just backwards